vous le savez le constructeur renault
est en grande difficulté financière
après la crise du coc vie de 19
l'entreprise a décidé d'un plan
d'économies de 2 milliards d'euros et
pourrait fermer son usine de
choisy-le-roi en ile de france une usine
qui est spécialisée dans le
reconditionnement des boîtes de vitesse
et des moteurs depuis hier les salariés
bloquent l'usiné ont fait le point sur
place avec notre reporter pierre pissavy
yvernault bonjour pierre alors les
salariés de l'usiné renault de
choisy-le-roi bloque donc l'entrée du
site depuis hier ils sont de retour
aujourd'hui c'est bien ça tout à fait et
me vous l'avez dit un hier ce sont près
de 200 personnes qui ont bloqué ici le
site de choisy-le-roi situé en région
parisienne plus précisément dans le val
de marne ils sont de retour 1 ce matin
pour bloquer une nouvelle fois ce site
que renault a prévu de fermer à
l'horizon 2022 alors pourquoi cette
probable fermeture et bien tout
simplement parce que vous l'avez dit
encore une fois renault est en grande
difficulté financière et annoncé
notamment un plan d'économies de 2
milliards d'euros un plan d'économies
qui prévoit notamment le licenciement de
4600 personnes d'ici trois ans et donc
la fermeture de ceux ci de choisy le roi
des salariés qui regrette justement de
ne pas avoir été consulté après cette
décision
je vous propose de les écouter tout le
monde à construire autour une vie autour
de cette usine un moment repartir sa
posture mais ce sera pas ce ne sera pas
entre la commande en un claquement de
doigts on est là tu quand même pas mal
d'années il ya des années difficiles il
ya des années on va dire heureux où tout
va bien encore ça va pas tout le monde
est prêt à donner un coup de main c'est
notre entreprise on est on est là pour
la faire vivre aussi
donc on peut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui à
des difficultés et qu'il faut y faire
face
mais il faut expliquer les choses
j'attends des réponses
on attend tous des réponses à nos
questions savoir pourquoi le site de
renault choisit qui incite rentable va
être délocalisée sur flins en sachant
que nous on allie tous aux alentours de
70 km de choisy alors ça paraît
peut-être pas loin sur la carte mais en
région parisienne ça nous fait deux
heures 12 heures et demie aller deux
heures deux heures et demie retour c'est
impossible on a les structures on a les
infrastructures déjà on a les vapes au
concentrateur en atout on a les fosses
pour on a tout ce qu'il faut on a le
personnel qui est fort mais qui est
compétent donc voilà qui nous expliquent
pourquoi ils vont nous délocaliser
surface je vous le disais il était
environ 200 hier ils sont un peu plus
aujourd'hui de nombreuses personnes sont
venues apporter leur soutien aux
salariés de l'usiné renault de
choisy-le-roi on a vu notamment des
salariés de l'usiné de sandouville
renault sandouville cette usine située
près du havre
notamment on a vu également des soutiens
de l' usine de douai on a vu à l'instant
l'arrivée du secrétaire général de la
cgt philippe martinez et puis beaucoup d
sharp bleu blanc rouge
ici ce matin sur le site de choisy le
roi à ce sont des élus qui sont venus
apporter leur soutien aux salariés
c'était notamment le cas du sénateur du
val-de-marne pascal savoldelli je vous
propose de l'écouter il ya un nouveau
rassemblement devant l'entreprise qui a
été décidé par les salariés et par
l'ensemble des syndicats d'ailleurs du
site de choisy le roi et j'ai pu voir
qu'il ya d'autres salariés qui vient
les soutenir j'ai croisé des salariés
d'edf par exemple d'autres qui viennent
les soutenir pour défendre à la fois
l'existence de ce site de choisy de
renault vous savez qui est menacé comme
taux de sites de renault en france et
qui a une particularité c'est que le
site dans lequel on est là c'est un site
qui a été reconnue label écologique du
point de vue de l'économie circulaire
c'est à dire que c'est un des fleurons
de renault alors voilà sur l'ensemble
des sites français seuls 6 de
choisy-le-roi seraient concernés par une
probable fermeture pas question pour
l'instant de licencier les 262 salariés
de choisy le roi
le constructeur français prévoit tout
pour l'instant un transfert d'activités
vers al usine de flins située elle aussi
en région parisienne mais environ à deux
heures de transport
ici c'est en tout cas ce que regrettent
les salariés du site renault de
choisy-le-roi aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
de pierres pissavy yvernault pour toutes
ces précisions on vous retrouve dans nos
prochaines éditions pour suivre
l'évolution de la situation